And a lot of you guys are passing along. You don't even know it yet.
I might have it. I might have it. I don't think I have it, but I might have it.
You know what? I don't even not think I have it. Do you know why?
Because I heard that Aegis Elba. Got it.
So that means that sexy guys can get it. So it's like,
I thought maybe I was immune. Cause I'm tall, dude. I'm a tall drink of water.
You know, he drew his album,
got it from all of his DJ sets that he's been doing to cause he's been to and
too many DJ sets, but that sucks, man,
word up to Idris Elba gave a great message out on Twitter was very
positive about it. No pun intended. But uh, and then Tom Hanks to man,
two of Tom Hanks, America's sweetheart and Aegis Elba, man.
That's that's that's rough. I love Hydra Silva, L Elba. And I love Tom Hanks,
but the, you know, when Tom Hanks got it, I was like, okay,
he's more of an every man, but when EGIS Elba got it, I'm like, Oh great,
sexy guys can get it. I'm Corona virus.
Doesn't they don't give a if you make panties wet. Oh, dude.
They don't care how many towels you have to pass out. Ah, for sake, dude.
Oh great.
So now I got to just chill in doors. I'm indoors dude, and I'm keeping it cool.
And every, every, every five seconds I feel do I feel even dude,
the crazy thing is I've been leaving it on CNN and also Fox news.
I flipped back and forth. Cause baby, I'm not, you know what I mean? I like to,
I like to get the whole picture. I like take some CNN. I take some Fox news.
I put it together and I did just what I had to do because I'm real person. Okay.
And then when I do that, there's so much going on about the,
uh, what do you call it? Um, coronavirus that, then I start thinking, Oh,
I have a cough. Even though I don't have a cough and I haven't coughed,
I think I'll have a cough. Uh,
so that just proves to you how crazy I am and how the media can get to you.
Uh, so thanks a lot media. But yeah,
I love how people still think and not a big deal. Don't worry about it. I don't,
I'm not showing symptoms. Like it's not a problem.
You can get it and then it do this. Anything else? You get it.
And then in four days you get sick. That's how the flu is.
If you shake someone's hands with the flu, you don't go, Oh,
I have a fever immediately. Dude, you go home, you chill a little bit.
You watch some Netflix, you wake up the next morning. All things are good.
You go get a Starbucks and you spread it a little bit.
And then you come back home.
And then later on that night you feel a little fatigue, but you're like,
maybe it'll be pass them and get some sleep.
And then the next day you wake up and it sucks. Babies.
But life still rips, man.
You have to keep that in the back of your head.
Okay. Because I can't handle another famous actor getting this Corona virus,
man. I thought maybe it will be cool if I was the first one,
because then I would get more press. But I'm not, it's fine, Tom Hanks, ESL,
but they got it. And maybe it could be third,
but yeah, we're coming at you responsibly, man, uh,
with the, with the, with the mask on. Uh,
but I love how just some people,
just some people how they think it's a hoax and is just out of control.
Some people think here, where's the thing.
Now this idiot Janna Abraham, Abraham corsets, her name,
widest name of all time, Janet Abraham
and uh, downtown Nashville is undefeated. And then,
and then.
[Inaudible].
First of all this music, you know what I mean?
Yeah.
Yeah. I don't give a what goes on down by the river or you know.
Down by the river in the. And I'm Robin.
Freaks in a break-ins in a Verena. My brains do it. I don't give a.
Take off your cowboy hat, cowboy hat, go home. Pick up your cowboy hat,
put on a face mask and goggles go home.
Nashville's undefeated got news for you Gina. In two weeks,
Nashville going to be defeated. Cause this is the Corona virus.
This isn't a baseball team.
Just be responsible, dude. Oh, I love the people. Look, Janet left that up too.
She didn't give a.
Heck of a job, Tennessee. Somebody writes, it's not tennis. I love T I,
you know, Tennessee's cool, but it's just.
Man.
Current crowds at the magic kingdom for tonight's showing of happily ever after
last, last night, Disney world. I mean so many people
They say you're supposed to hold your breath for 10, 10 seconds and you go
And if you cough, you're. I didn't cough. yeah.
Oh.
Yeah dude. I'm good. So I'm good. I don't have it. I'll try again and you know,
a little bit, but uh, one farmer is doing it. If he coughs he's out,
go leave. Um, see that's the thing now I feel like,
I think I have to cough and then I, but I don't dude. It's my OCD.
Um.
So anyway, uh, eater, Salba. Got it. Tom Hanks. Got it.
It's just brutal, dude.
Well get better quick Tom Hanks and eaters Elba. I love you guys.
I think you're awesome. And I really hope that you guys, well,
you'll make it through because you're you guys. I mean, you guys,
you're going to have the best medical, although the guy, well, I don't want to,
I don't, you know what? I'm not going to get into it.
The guy who was the head of the thing in Italy, he died, but all good. No,
I mean, he obviously got the best medical attention and he died,
but it's all good. I, you know, I feel bad. He was only 50 something,
but it's all good. But so anyway.
Um.
We are self quarantining, quarantining, my babies. We're doing it, man.
And you got it too.
Cause that's what cause life's ripping and you got to keep making sure life
rips. So stay in doors for two weeks.
If we stayed indoors for two weeks and then we got out of doors,
it will be fine, but you guys are going to be, you're going to be,
we're going to be bored, dude.
I've been quarantined for two days and I'm bored as.
I've watched a documentary on Wells Fargo last night. I mean I do. Hey,
listen to me, dude. Look at me, look at me,
look at me in the YouTube chits. And if you're not, if you're listening to it,
I want you to take your fingers and push on your headset or
whatever the hell you got. You got those,
those AirPods that come out all the time when you jump.
Cause I jump a lot because I do lots of cardio, but I want you to listen to me,
dude. I've been self, self quarantining, quarantining. that. You know what dude,
I've been staying indoors. that word. Okay. But I'm telling you right now.
Look at me in the YouTube. Make eye contact with me.
I'm so bored. I watched a documentary on Wells Fargo last night.
Okay. So this is what I'm doing for the.
All right, this is what I'm doing for the country.
So if I'm sitting at home watching a Wells Fargo documentary,
you guys can do it too. Or at least sit at home and like play Jenga with people.
But, but, but people who are in your circle, you know,
maybe gender is not the best because you got to touch everything.
But you know what I mean?
It's a self quarantine special from, uh, congratulations,
log cabin. Uh,
I'm glad they canceled Coachella,
even though that's the place they should have kept open because those people
deserve to all.
Um, anyway, uh.
It's all good.
You should definitely not go to Coachella because you don't want to get the
coronavirus. But if you did,
wouldn't wouldn't really be the end of the world because those are the people
that should.
Get it anyway.
And specifically the people in stagecoach also don't care.
So that's so anyway, uh.
Or anywhere they play this song. Oh dude,
this. I'm going to the strip club after this and getting it. I don't give a.
Give me a lap dance. Let me cough, baby.
Give me a lap dance and watch me cough in two weeks.
Oh, ah, ah dude. Hey baby.
Here's $20.
Show me your. Yeah dude.
We did not stop.
We make sure people get content no matter what,
I will reschedule the shows,
but we make sure that we make content for people.
I might go out and get a book deal for y'all because I need to keep making this
money and bags need to keep coming in. I'll write a book.
You think I won't write a book. I'll write a book anyway.
I'm slowly losing my mind. It's been one day next week.
I'll be quarantined for one week and then next week I'll be quarantined for two
weeks. Oh my God. For real, I will be nuts.
Anyway, dude, who, um,
what was I trying to say about the Italy's been killing it though. It,
you can't make, here's the thing about Italians.
There's so emotional
that they're either going to turn it into the worst thing or the best thing.
And they figured out how to turn it into the best thing. I mean, dude, Italy,
there's videos of out, out there where people are just singing from rooftops
and just, and like from their apartments are all opened up facing each other.
And they're just like.
[Inaudible].
And people are just like,
[inaudible] There's guys out there for real, with trumpets and harps,
you know.
[Inaudible] guys.
That's the most Italian thing to take a tragedy and turn it into the most
beautiful.
Everybody in Italy shed one tear.
When they found out the Corona virus was there and then they go like this,
get my trumpet.
At the least we can, at least we kind of sing that.
That is the most Italian thing you can possibly say it.
At least it cannot stop me from singing
opened the window. That's what happened when Italy,
when Italy found out that they were going to get the Corona virus,
they go like this, they shed
The shed one tear and then they go like this, open the window.
And that's the most Italian thing of all time. And now let me tell you why,
because you let the emotion hit yet. It'll let it sink in.
You let that one tear shed out and then you make it from the most emotional,
sad thing. And you turn it to the most emotional, beautiful thing.
Thinking at least I can still sing.
And you say open at the window and now let me tell you why it's even more at a
time because the man is saying that to the woman and he wants a woman to open
the window for him. That's why, because he's like you do it,
do things for me so I can give people my gift. Hello,
lesser than open at the window. And then she opens it. Yes.
And she opens it and he just steps outside.
[Inaudible].
And then some guy goes like this, what is that downstairs? Well, what is that?
And then she says, they're singing. And then he says why?
And then she says,
apparently the Corona virus has come to Italy and he sheds one tear from
the other eye to make it even,
and then he says open at the window and then he steps out.
[Inaudible] you know, that song
that they always played during some sad. Or if someone gets married
[inaudible].
What's that one? That's the cat song, dude. But they're singing it in Italian.
And then, and then dude, and then one guy says,
what is that from [inaudible]? And she says, they're singing.
And he says why? And she says,
because apparently the coronavirus is in Italy now. And then he said,
and then they say that he says,
and then he lets two tiers down from both eyes because he realizes two people
are singing and they both know, and it's even more tragic.
And then it goes like this
Open at the window. And she said, and she just walks over, slides,
open the door and he walks out, get my trumpet.
Okay.
And then it's beautiful. And then they figured out all the, man.
They figured out after that, they figured out to, there was a workout class.
Some guy was standing on a lower building from the inside of
surrounded, by a bunch of other buildings. And he was doing workout,
video workout, uh, videos, workout classes,
and everyone was joining him from their patio set stallion.
What's the song. They always sing not the cat song. I sang the cat song,
but let me, let me get the video on YouTube, Italy, Italy,
singing, singing, Corona virus.
Here we go. This is the song they sing always.
First of all, it's so late at night. How annoyed would I be?
Yeah,
[inaudible] kind of a beautiful thing though. [inaudible].
So tone deaf. It's just so blitz. Drunk,
ate so much pasta and just.
Ruined.
It. There's going to be one guy that ruins it. You know,
just some skinny string bean guy too, that everyone's like, God,
that guy is so annoying. But for some reason he can fight.
And.
It just, how come every foreign country has a song with Olay in it.
I swear to God every foreign country, that guy would be,
I would be living next to that guy. And I would be like this, dude.
How Italian is it to sing on patios to each other?
When some emotional goes down and I would be the F here's me do it
now I'm young as. But act like an old guy. Sometimes I'll be like,
they're singing. I turn over to my girl. They're singing. And it's so annoying,
dude. And we got a quarantine and now I can't get sleep and she'd be like,
it's a beautiful thing. And I'd be like, God opened the window.
[Inaudible].
Oh, that's that. That's that girl.
That's always that's that girl that talks and get you in a fight at a bar.
Well, that's why he's a fat rotten. That's whole. And you're like, baby,
can you? And he's like, what did she saying? Nothing, baby.
She just had a few drinks. Not with that in mind, boy, he going to beat you up,
baby, please. And then you're in a fight. That's that girl.
And same.
Note, four times, not even trying,
bro. This Corona virus really, really it's
Firing on all cylinders. They were saying that, uh,
it's not in a virus's best interest to kill, to be high,
to be killing people quickly that it's going to take them a long time to like,
it stays in you for awhile and then kills you because they want it.
They want you to go out and to transmit it to other people and, and,
and its whole goal is to spread. And that.
That.
Is the scariest thing that I've ever heard.
[Inaudible].
Oh good. So virus is try to just lay in what this is. This is what, uh,
this is a virus right here.
Virus just chilling.
And then before you know,
it it's too late and you're sitting on the patio just
In the meantime she has it probably.
And she's given it to other people in the apartment complex, but it's, you know,
the world's gone mad, but at times figured that man,
shout out to the Italians. I'm really sorry. That sucks, man.
They were going through a hard time though. For real.
I know there's just a silly goose. This,
this is a silly goose time on this podcast,
but they're going through a hard time.
I know no dents and this is a silly CO's time and everything, but.